[Music]
three two one action
hey guys welcome back to off-the-record
where we talk about whatever we want and
today we have Aaron make sure you have
listened to with them with Griffin right
away to Eric Griffin comedy okay
drop the phone talk about just you know
all kinds of stuff I've had Bobby on and
his brother Bobby Lee and Steve Lee I've
had them Monica a few times we just
talked about herpes yeah we have them
too yeah I know yeah you got this
because of them on here it's my Asian
connection right there you know I mean
so yeah but I just do a lot of stuff
like that but but other than that I've
just been like traveling and you know
doing my thing
I just went to London that's okay it
just like New York it's look exactly
like yeah I'm not a city person anybody
need that like when I go on vacation I
want a beach Sam by the way I want my
this is what I want I want my door to be
here I want to yeah and the [ __ ]
water needs to be like I could like
throw a pillow and it's floating in the
water because like I went to I went to
the Cook Islands one year okay it's it's
like the Hawaii of New Zealand oh by the
way a very affordable vacation and it's
beautiful right but then sorry but after
that we flew into Oakland because I
wanted to like I wanted to go see the
Lord of the Rings sex I'm a nerd like
that but as we're driving from the
airport to the hotel I was like this is
like downtown LA that's how disappointed
you would be like you know it's like
there's a mobile station there's a movie
poster there's McDonald's it's like oh
that's what I realized from traveling
like every big city pretty much like
what they say like my blindfold of you
and dropped you in any mall yeah you
would you'd be like oh where am i some
cities smell more like pissed and the
other ones that's true and install like
if you go through those cities you're
like well New York for sure
New York is the stinkiest steamie Hong
Kong's play one of ours
I don't know cuz in New York you can
like it's like you could smell [ __ ] oh
yeah they have an open sewer system
right where nobody in York you can smell
human [ __ ] yeah if you go to Taiwan you
can smell human [ __ ] but it comes from a
dish people eat it comes from a
restaurant oh it's not actual [ __ ]
people are eating it yeah I haven't been
that's I have I do want to go to like
Thailand Hong Kong I haven't done that
yet it makes any like major Western
major city look like the village yeah it
is different it's insane but I'm just
I'm just like I'm just not a city guy
but I do like going to some European
countries because you get this like
sense of like history yeah yeah like
ancient yeah that the old stuff like
Germany's good but Germany's very modern
but then at the same time they'll be
like a church like this church has been
here for three thousand years or
whatever it is you know this place
called my Orca in Spain yes alright so
that I haven't been there but everyone's
saying it's got the best of both worlds
where it has all this ancient [ __ ] like
ancient like yeah I don't have like a
little Coliseum type yeah yeah like
stones and stuff and like buildings that
crumbled and stuff and then there's like
a bomb-ass beach that has clear water
and actually yeah you swimming in and
it's like so you want a little bit
history and you want a little bit of
beach yeah which is Sydney I went to
Sydney Australia and okay first of all
one of the most expensive places I've
ever been and it's just it was just like
a city cleaner la favorite place I've
ever been you know actually I think it
was - Cook Islands have you been to Bali
I haven't been the boss you got a Bali
but see I don't like going to places
where like when you fly in you have to
fly in and it's like you feel like you
could get kidnapped no because you guys
are tripping because there's
to reap warm and welcoming okay Costa
Rica's different I've been to both I
love Costa Rica but Bali is such a
spiritual Island like everyone there is
spiritual they printed out like incense
and stuff every day and like like
offerings and stuff they're so warm and
welcoming I've never been to anywhere
like it but the places but those kind of
places you fly in and then you're just
trying to get to the resort yeah and
then that's like paradise yeah yeah then
there's kidnapping situations in the
middle yeah that's what I'm saying like
what I was in Costa Rica I was like what
yeah from the airport yes I get me -
that's like Mexico yeah was like that's
it you know it's like how you who's been
to Costa Rica you've been to Costa Rica
but did you go to the beach over you're
in the rainforest no I was at the beach
Bryce oh yeah yeah yeah no no I wanted
to but then I can't go to both I was in
love with this like this resort I was
that oh my where was it room service
it was like one of those like it was one
of those like chain oh the for the like
guy supports these sandals or something
yeah yeah yes but it was like that it
was a name like that and you had to say
it like that too you know it was like a
European like a perfume commercial
you're gonna mean South long and it's
like a famous person that you didn't
know did commercials but yeah but I like
that those are the type I just want to
be I want to be on a beach now
yeah scene sorry we're not a beach sorry
you got white girls but not enough you
know me there's like two in two halves
no but I'm actually going to be to
vacation Busan Aruba Oh
well they goes monetization tip you
traveled a lot what's your favorite
place you ever been oh my god hands down
has to be Croatia Oh mysterious
so there's this region of Croatia a sex
tour no so there's this like little
region called Istria and it's like right
across the Adriatic Sea from Italy that
region is to [ __ ] die for
it's like Italy but without all the
crazy tourists it's like an untouched
Italy by the way I that is something but
when I said about the Cook Islands there
wasn't any Americans like that's
something that like I don't like going
like I hate going to Ensenada or
anyplace like that yeah yeah cuz I'm
like Long Beach white people everywhere
each where they put like a Mexican cent
like it's like you wanna you want to get
with the natives you want to find out
like you know the foods and all that
kind of stuff yeah well we actually got
to go with the Tourism Board of istria
so they got to like the best of the
region that what that vacation was like
I could just die happy there it was
amazing and then they're known for
truffles so every dish had like I'm just
making truffle it was truffle everything
I just I just want to like hear water
splashing that's blush you should go to
[ __ ] Bali no cuz you're like you're
like all in one hand like I want to go
right to the resort but then I want to
be with the natives and like the locals
and know Americans like make a choice
yeah I just don't want the natives that
like seems scary scary oh my god it's
just so far away it is from Bora Bora is
what I'm thinking of like yeah but Bora
Bora is the place where you went from
the airport to the thing if you need
like 12 flights to get there's a weird
there's no one stop look at every don't
look into it it takes like [ __ ] 19
hours to get some by the way about Cook
Islands direct flight from LA that's
what I like before you go to Bora Bora
I've looked into this oh you really want
to go but what's top is fine yeah thing
for me is I don't fly coach so but it's
like a minimum if you go like to Bora
Bora for a week it's like a minimum like
30 grand you're spinning it's like a
no-name package that's for five nights
for two people flights included from LA
it's like about eleven thousand dollars
and it includes like jet skis snorkel
yeah but you know what don't do that
kind of stuff I learned my lesson like
when you go to a place don't get food
packages don't get none of that [ __ ]
because you're not gonna you're not
you're not gonna get the value because
when you're on vacation you don't have
structured eating you're not like we
gotta go to breakfast we got to go to
lunch we go to dinner sometimes you just
might be like we're gonna skip that and
you've wasted that money it's better to
pay per play well this one doesn't have
a food yeah but that's what I heard is
that that's what ends up costing the
most money is cause like you want a
burger
it's like forty dollars yeah it's like
every little thing is way more expensive
than here I want to go to Maldives
asylum oh yeah that seems that looks
like a straw hut in the middle of the
ocean
oh this is the one where you look at the
internet and it's just like a strip of
sand and it's beaches on both sides and
it's like clearance and there you have
like private private beaches and stuff
like that so it's like you waste all
your money yeah yeah that's too much
beach for you too much water you just
want the one it might be only water I
need to be able to get to my room I mean
I need to be able to get room service I
mean I'm very picky yeah
first of all if I'm spending all this
money on vacation I need to get what I
want
I need a resort with no Americans I just
need the natives but not the scary ones
like I need the culture I know what food
packages open but I need to get to my
room
by the way Costa Rica what I liked about
this one was what was it called paradise
no whatever it was they it was 24-hour
room service it was part of it oh that's
amazing yeah yeah especially get sick
you need that yeah food was good but I
got so sick of course I know and then
you know that thing that just happened
you get sick you sick I knew there was a
catch nobody got step one time it wasn't
cause of the I know what it was it was
some sushi or something that I had one
meal that I had that I just was like oh
it was terrible it was very it was a big
test for this new relationship that I
was in oh you know what ruined Costa
Rica for me is my husband ruined it he
got kidney stones in the middle of it
I'm like [ __ ] I waited for this
vacation oh yeah I took my girl for
Christmas and it was like I don't know
it just it was still beautiful
we got couples massage and like you know
yeah you know just every setting like
every time you eat there's like you know
there's the ocean like you know mr.
diarrhea in the ocean yeah no but I
should have but I but I had stuff coming
out both ends it was I want to get
stayed in the ocean that feels warm it
was terrible I was like well we just
broke up you know what I was like I
don't know it was that was a tough one
that was at elevation with a vacation I
made the best of the vacation he keeps
wanting to go back to the vacation so
yeah but I want to go back to the
relationship too no no I want to go back
to that place but I want to go and do
what else yeah different situation
how long did that relation you've lost
almost two years that's a good test when
we first started dating I was staying
over at her place I threw up I [ __ ] in
her bathtub this is the first way you
[ __ ] in her back that was the craziest
thing boys anymore whatever I've ever
felt quite a bit that was there with you
because it's just so I don't know what
happened but it's just coming out like I
was [ __ ] on the toilet like crazy
and I was throwing up between my legs
then I thought it ended oh no I thank
God I'm gonna take a hot shower get
myself clean because there's just
splatter everywhere oh and then I'm
going to go sleep I go in the bathtub
and I throw up and then all it's not the
shits on my [ __ ] I've never [ __ ]
standing up I just start pushing no no
sometimes you don't even have to push it
you didn't say you pushed even walking
dirty bastard well it came out and then
I've ever shouldn't have you got dyrus
standing up no I have it's pretty
interesting when he hits the bathroom
that bounces back up so it'll go down
all I hit me in the chin and then where
the drain is like a man or something up
at the same time this is crazy yeah
you're not thinking about that at that
time you're not like you're not sitting
going like I got to make sure no you do
think because I was in a very similar
situation yeah and as soon as I came out
because I was showering - I was I I was
I had the worst review with Casey
already yeah man actually recently
[Music]
Cameron that's like pointing out yeah so
it was that time we went to Vegas you
guys are all there actually oh yes when
I got food poisoning right before
leaving
I was [ __ ] dying on vacation not
really sick to you Japan well that was
an emotional distress throw up
alright numbers a difference that was
difference no but um but yes so at that
time that I got food poisoning I was
trying to shower in the hotel room and
then all of a sudden I'm like oh my god
oh yeah but Hotel roses for the hotel
room and then I used a mouse it started
flashing you know just like nope it's
hard to like cuz it down I was squatting
right by the drain I was like I've never
done this in my life
this is [ __ ] crazy yeah did you smell
the room oh yeah I made sure I rinse
everything I it was very cool I try I
really tried to do it splatter on the
curtain on the like the shower thing I
didn't know about this at all nasty
inside the gene what I'd like the bottle
was after I came out and then she knew
that I was horrible like I felt horrible
well cuz I didn't know you pushed but
even after having to throw up it's like
a cramp that you can't you can't help it
but it's just like I'll get the [ __ ] out
just like so you're saying you pushed or
it just came out no so the initial one
it just keep us good I ended up pushing
that's right yeah that's I did you feel
me both push these [ __ ] pushers
what do you want to trap it in press it
like you're feeling holding in a
throw-up like you can't yeah thank you
coming I've held in throw-ups we're just
not gross is the thing oh you are we
don't know what that is we just have
stomach cramps all the [ __ ] time yeah
we never we never let it
strong that I couldn't hold it enough
disgusting things happened to women's
bodies anyway I mean you know no I'm
just saying you already have enough
discount savings tips body you guys so
much you have to deal with as it is you
know everything was trying to leave her
body I'm glowing
breastfeeding at the same time that'd be
terrible yeah but that was pretty bad so
you ended up planning everything
why clean everything and then what I
thought what I thought would she was the
keeper was so you don't yeah like yak
breath it's all sleeping in the bedroom
she depress your teeth I then for that
didn't you were saying if she was a
keeper wait he was sick no no when I
came back no one when I came back don't
know what she came back from work and
she the first thing she did was kiss me
to make sure that I was awesome she
loves it was a peck plus you think that
you just she pees what did you have
earlier she picked you in your life okay
I'll keep her yeah I just shat all over
the shower what you want it like that is
exactly the sign of like a good
relationship yeah you know that's why
I'm always I didn't know he pushed okay
harping on the pole relationship
everybody pushes pushed in the [ __ ]
shower oh my god what was he supposed to
do hold it hold it and then go to the
toilet
carpet plug it in there was no carpet I
was on the bathroom if I would have held
it the minute I crossed over the bathtub
level would opened up on the bathroom
light for clothes and when he would have
stepped over butthole open spray put a
tampon in there just we all do it
noodle accepted that because you can't
control that his butt cheeks open but so
once you find out about the [ __ ] in the
shower
Oh months later months later I know you
found a speckle though feces in your
life but how did you bring that up well
you just like hey funny story sorted
[ __ ] all over your back remember there
at dinner and he was like it's like when
I show over Gio's bathroom that's how I
find [ __ ] out especially I'm Jake he
knees I'm like really yeah so something
like that oh yeah that was our
relationship that's cute that's cute
work do you know better love story than
Twilight it is such a great leave
Twilight alone I read all that I read
all vampire books I just I just said I
love the genre but like first of all
Twilight is a perfect female love story
cuz it's about a guy it's about a girl
who here's a guy who lost lover - dude
no he's a hundred and seventeen years
old but he said but he's got a 17 year
old body he doesn't want to have sex
before marriage he wants to protect her
he's intoxicated by her smell and then
and then there's another guy who's a
werewolf too hot guys were after her
it's all a fairy tale that's my story
right there - guys you guys should know
this but the pieces together real wife
they would have been running a train on
her but no it was romantic so it's a
very romantic I was just quoting a meme
since while I light are not real no you
should want to quote a mean but all
people don't get it
what we do in the shadows yes did you
like it yeah the movie and the TV TV
shows a live TV show they actually
quoted Twilight how they put it like
glitter all over what we do in the
shadow mmm oh yeah I seen it with
Jemaine yeah
[Music]
[Music]